(brooding music)
(ambient music)
- 2022 has been a really
fascinating year for movies.
I'm pretty hopeful
about cinema in general.
I think there's a lot of quality
stuff being made out there.
It's just having to compete
with this endless void
of near infinite content
that's coming at us from
all directions right now.
My top 10 list is very loosely ranked.
What makes it onto the
list usually gets there
because of one or more of three things.
How well the movie resonated
with me emotionally,
which is very personally
subjective, obviously.
My interest level in the
ideas, themes, and concepts
that it's exploring.
And then third, how well the movie
is kind of wielding filmmaking as a form
and/or pushing the
boundaries of that medium
to do something that feels
new, original, and fresh to me.
Actually trying to establish
what the best movies from a year were
is a total fool's errand,
especially before the year is even over.
There are still a bunch of movies
that potentially would've
made it onto this list
that I haven't had the time to see
or just aren't even
available for me to watch.
But what these lists are good
for is starting a discussion.
So let's hang out, talk about movies,
and share with me your
top 10 from this year
in the comments below.
Final note, I will keep
this list spoiler-free
so you can watch this
without worrying about
whether or not you've seen any
of the movies on this list.
This video is sponsored by MUBI.
Get your extended 30-day free trial
at mubi.com/thomasflight.
First, let's get to
some honorable mentions.
So there are two movies
that I got to see at Cannes
earlier this year.
Lukas Dhont's "Close"
and also Kelly Reichardt's "Showing Up,"
but I'm bumping them to
the running for next year
because they're getting a wide
release in the US in 2023,
but they would almost certainly be
in my top 10 for this year.
Other honorable mentions are "After Yang"
from video
essayist-turned-director Kogonada.
"After Yang" is a soft, kind
of gentle science fiction film
that I think really shows what
can be done with the genre
at that smaller scale.
In a genre where a lot of stuff
is huge, big, high concept,
often dark or sort of dystopian,
it's cool to watch something
that just puts forward
a more simple, beautiful
science fiction world.
I also wanna mention "The
Worst Person in the World"
from Joachim Trier that
released way back in February,
which is a genuinely funny
and emotional indictment
of kind of millennial malaise
that I think still manages
to be compassionate
and insightful,
all while doing so with
kind of stylistic flair.
I also wanna mention "White Noise,"
the Noah Baumbach adaptation
of the "Don DeLillo" novel.
I love the novel and I
don't know if this movie
quite manages to elevate the novel,
but it was fun to see a
really faithful adaptation
in theaters and it's a fun movie.
Finally, I wanna mention "Memoria"
by Apichatpong Weerasethakul.
This is a movie that came out last year,
but which is still slowly
touring theaters city by city.
I really loved this kind of bizarre,
meditative art house sci-fi,
and I can't wait to watch it
again once it's out on video.
But in the meantime,
I definitely recommend keeping an eye out.
And if it comes to your
city, check it out.
Now, let's jump into my
loosely ranked top 10 of 2022.
Different people are gonna want
different things from the movies,
and one of the things
I've always really valued
for whatever reason is commitment.
Commitment to the vision,
commitment to a concept,
a story, a perspective.
Nine out of 10 times,
I'd rather watch a movie
shoot for something really
interesting and specific
and miss slightly
rather than watch somebody absolutely nail
what is a tried and true formula.
The main appeal of Robert
Eggers' films for me is this.
His 100% absolute commitment to the bit.
And for me, "The Northman"
completely exemplifies this.
In a year of really unique movies,
there's truly no other
movie like "The Northman"
that came out this year.
There's an attention
to lore and detail here
that I really appreciate,
but I think most interestingly,
to me, it feels like
the movie really commits
to the perspective of
the myth it's telling.
"The Northman" doesn't feel
like a movie about a myth.
It feels like a myth itself,
like what Vikings might make
if they got their hands on cameras.
Next up on the list is
"Decision to Leave,"
a razor-sharp neo-noir
from South Korean Director Park Chan-Wook.
It's built around a convoluted,
twisted mystery that rivals
the best noirs out there.
This is one of those like
double indemnity kind of plots
about two people who
are absolutely perfectly
terrible for each other and
just watching them collide
in a disastrous mess that
you can't look away from.
And you won't wanna look away
because Park is flying you
through the very heart
of this relationship
with the camera at breakneck speed.
He's putting cameras in eyeballs
and phones and flying the
camera around through time
and moving characters in space.
I've never seen someone intercut
the beginning of one scene
with the end of another in
the way he does in this movie.
Like one out of every
three shots in this movie
is absolutely stunning.
It kind of astounds me
that he was able to pack
so much interesting, fresh,
original direction into one film
and it's a great compelling story,
but it's also worth checking out
just for studying what
he's doing in this film.
(waves crashing)
(guns banging)
- Oh, good luck to you,
whatever it is you're fighting about.
- Next up is "The Banshees of Inisherin."
This movie brings back
the Gleason-Farrell duo
that I loved from one of Martin
McDonagh's earlier films,
"In Bruges."
And it's a very different
relationship here,
but the duo is no less compelling.
It's a movie about conflict
between two friends,
but that conflict is really emblematic
of other larger conflicts
in a way that is really
interesting and works really well.
There's an examination of the value of art
versus the value of kind of friendship
and respect for other people.
The conflict is also emblematic
of larger conflict in Ireland
and loss of meaning within
this specific community.
And to that end,
I think this movie has maybe
the strongest sense of place
out of any movie that I watched this year.
So it's kind of a cliche to say,
like the location is a character,
but it's really true here.
Not just in how the location is shot
with the cinematography,
which I think is some of the
best photography I've ever seen
of Irish landscape in a movie,
but also just in how
the pace of island life
kind of seeps into even the
delivery of the dialogue
and the editing of the film.
You really feel like
you're inside this place
and that allows you to
understand the impact
that being there has on
all of the characters.
And all the characters are amazing.
Some of the best performances
from a supporting cast this year, I think,
are in this movie.
This movie immerses you in a world
and by the end you're gonna be
haunted by the same banshees
as everyone else on the island.
(brooding music)
(roof banging)
People who watch my channel know that,
like the bigger blockbuster stuff
isn't necessarily my usual vibe,
but I think this was actually
kind of an amazing year
for larger blockbuster films.
I think Ryan Coogler's, "Wakanda Forever"
was one of the most interesting MCU films
that I've seen in a long time.
I think he was pushing what
you can do with an MCU film
in an interesting direction.
"The Batman" is by far
the best superhero movie
I've seen in a long time
in terms of production.
I made a video about its sound
design earlier this year.
We also had "Top Gun: Maverick,"
which kind of came out of nowhere.
So I wanted to ask my podcast
co-host, Tom van der Linden,
why he thought that movie
deserves to be among the best of the year.
"Top Gun: Maverick" was one of
the biggest movies this year
in terms of theatrical audience response,
and it's a movie I enjoyed,
but I think struggled to connect with
in the same way that I
feel like a lot of people
who really enjoyed it did.
And I know it's a movie
that you really liked, Tom,
so I'm just curious of your thoughts on
why you think "Top Gun"
deserves to be considered
one of the the best movies of this year.
- I think that for me,
I have no nostalgia towards the original.
I kind of went into this one blind
and I expected it to be
this great action movie.
You know, Tom Cruise has
been well known by now
for doing all this stuff
for real and practically
and there were this real fighter jets
and it was gonna be really
cool, and indeed it was.
But what surprised me
was that it was actually very emotional
in the sense that there was
this underlying sense of,
I'd call it heroic optimism
in the way that the whole story felt.
Like it had this energy wherein
people could come together,
they could work together,
elevate each other by pushing
each other to the limits,
and then go beyond them and
achieve this common goal
or common purpose.
And I felt like there
was just something so
universally beautiful about that
even though there's the relation
with the military and war,
which we've discussed,
but which I had a little
bit of an easier time
to disconnect from,
seeing as I'm not from a
very militaristic country.
But yeah, for me, it just,
that energy is for me
what kind of resonated
the strongest with me
and what made this movie
so moving beyond its
initial experience or its
superficial experience
almost as a pure action film.
- I really thought "Top Gun"
might be unabashedly
the most sincere movie
that we were gonna get this year,
but it might be rivaled by my pick
for favorite kind of big
blockbuster of the year,
which to my utter surprise,
I'm finding is "Avatar 2."
I really did not expect this
movie to be on this list
and it was a last minute edition.
And despite kind of liking the original,
I had pretty lukewarm
expectations going into this one.
And I wasn't sure at first,
there's a lot of rough edges here.
This is far from a perfect movie,
but over the course of this movie's
three-hour and 12-minute runtime
or whatever ridiculous length it is,
it kind of, to be honest, won me over.
This movie's VFX
are something that stand
completely on their own.
Watching this is really more
like playing "Half-Life: Alyx"
in VR than it is like watching a movie,
which is not to say better,
but just a completely unique
and kind of original
experience on its own.
That comparison
is probably either gonna
be a huge selling point
or downside depending on
your persuasion as a viewer.
A lot of that just comes
down to how much you enjoy
the visceral experience
of watching this movie,
but I honestly don't think the visuals
and beauty of the experience
are just an empty candy coating.
They're a critical part of the story.
James Cameron is trying to get you
to fall in love with this world,
and then he's putting that
world under direct attack
for dramatic effect.
And with these movies,
he's doing something really interesting,
which is modeling sort of
an attitude of engagement
with the world.
In these movies, it's aliens
engaging with a fake world,
but he's modeling a
certain type of curiosity
and attention and care that
can be given to the world
that is really an important
one to not lose sight of
for ourselves and our own real world.
I think we should be getting lost
in sort of the wonder and excitement
and joy of our own natural world.
And so to have a big blockbuster movie
kind of exemplifying that for
like an hour in the middle
is sort of a special thing.
I don't know of other movies
that come anywhere close
to doing that kind of thing
besides maybe like "The Tree of Life"
or the latest nature
documentary from Disney+.
"The Way of Water" never quite escapes
the high camp of James Cameron,
but if I'm gonna talk
about commitment in movies.
This movie is committed to whatever it is
that James Cameron is doing.
It's 100% committed and unexpectedly,
I found myself on board.
Our society is gripped
by spectacle right now.
Spectacle that is transmitted via images.
And the best,
most nuanced exploration of that this year
was probably Jordan Peele's "Nope."
I love that Jordan Peele
is doing this kind of thing
in his latest sort of
horror adventure spin.
"Nope" was the movie I had the most fun
picking apart this year.
And despite multiple viewings,
I still have the feeling
that there's more left there
to be discovered in the future.
The movie has an
incredible sense of rhyme.
There's seemingly disconnected elements
that are connected through
sound design or imagery
or thematic resonance
that might feel disparate at first,
but as you examine this
thing and re-watch it,
it really all kind of comes together
into this cohesive hole.
I think Peele's past
movies have been great,
but I'm also excited to see him
stepping into a kind
of thematic exploration
that's a little bit more poetic.
It has great sound, performances, writing.
It's the first horror movie shot on IMAX.
It pioneered a completely new form
of day for night cinematography.
There's way more I could say here,
but I'd just be repeating
what I've already said
in the two videos I made about "Nope."
So you can go check those
out if you're interested.
(locomotive chuffing)
Why do the greatest
directors that have lived
do what they do, make the art they make?
This is a question that
I find fascinating.
It's obviously one that
I've spent a lot of time
exploring on this channel,
and it's a question I love
because behind any piece of art
or entertainment that
captures the imagination
and attention of a bunch of viewers
is a person or group of people
who made that thing for a reason.
And those reasons don't
define the art itself,
but it's very interesting
still to examine those reasons
not only to better understand the art,
but so we can better understand ourselves,
why we connect with certain things,
and why we make the things we do.
So it's kind of fascinating
anytime a director turns
the lens more inward
and examines their own personal journey,
and that can be fraught, it
doesn't always turn out well.
Sometimes it's a more egoic
endeavor than anything,
but when Steven Spielberg does it,
it's a delight because he does it
in only the sort of personal,
completely heartfelt and captivating way
that Steven Spielberg could.
Sammy Fabelman is using the camera
to kind of cope and process
painful situations in his life.
And in a very explicit way,
we can also see Spielberg kind
of doing that with this film.
The strange bittersweet thing
about telling your own story like this
is that it can feel like this cohesive
thing to the audience.
But to the artist, these
things don't go away
when the credits roll.
It's their real life.
And putting your life into a
film to try to contain that
or frame it in a certain way
doesn't change the sort of
reality of those memories
or that situation.
I think the beauty of "The Fabelmans"
is that it doesn't
sidestep Spielberg's place
as this great filmmaker
in American history,
but it's still a surprisingly humble
and personal examination of the beauty
and limitations of the artistic process.
- I command you, enjoy the moment.
- No.
- Please.
- No
- The next best movie of the year
is "Mr. Morale and the
Big Steppers" by Kendrick.
One of the most interesting
songs of the year to me
was Kendrick Lamar's "We Cried Together."
It's a song that takes the form
of a vicious fight between a couple.
And there's a lot that
could be said about it,
but what I wanna
highlight here is, for me,
how the song captured a feeling
and that feeling is just
kind of what it feels like
to be listening to society right now.
This might sound completely bizarre,
but "Triangle of Sadness"
does that same maneuver in comedy form.
- Can you just stand here
and they'll be coming here?
- Okay.
- We'll see you.
- To me, what's great
about "Triangle of Sadness"
is not that it has this
profound specific message
or incredibly original
satire or commentary.
Mostly what I enjoyed about it
was the way that it
just managed to capture
the feeling of being in society right now.
It taps into a vibe in a comedic way
and that vibe is the absurdity
of being in the society
where things are kind of out of control
and a storm is battering the ship
and the upper class and
the lower class alike
are all just kind of having
to go about their business
and pretend like everything's fine
while the captain of the ship is drunk
and arguing about economic
theory with a Russian capitalist.
I love impressionist art.
There's few things as beautiful to me
as these paintings where you
can see the craft itself,
the impression of each brush stroke.
And if you really zoom in,
you'll get lost in a world of abstraction
and won't be able to make
out any of the details.
But as you pull back slowly,
the image itself kind of snaps into view.
I can think of no better way
to really describe "Aftersun,"
a stunning debut from
Director Charlotte Wells.
The movie doesn't announce
to you what it's doing.
Instead, you just sit there
with a series of small
light brush strokes.
A look here, a moment of dialogue there.
You can tell what's going on
literally with the characters,
but the why behind what's happening
is faint and obscured at first.
All you can see are
these individual shapes.
But as you slip deeper into the film,
it feels not like the movie
is telling you its story,
but as if it is emerging
from those strokes as a complete image.
You have a sense watching
it of discovering the story,
and then you realize
that all those shapes,
all those individual strokes are memories,
an effect that places
you in the perspective
of an adult character
actually looking back on
and remembering these events.
And for them, the story is also emerging
out of a collection of abstract strokes.
It's only from their
perspective as an adult now
that the story is snapping into place.
It's a beautiful shattering
film that is gentle, heartfelt,
nuanced, and it displays
how emotion can be complex
and confused more clearly than I think
any other film I've seen recently has.
"Tar" was the film I was
probably least expecting
to see this year.
I knew nothing about it going in.
I just knew this is a movie.
Cate Blanchett plays a composer.
What unfolded surprised me
by being one of the most dense,
fascinating character pieces
that I've seen in the theaters in years.
At the start of the film,
you're thrown into the deep end
of the world of pretentious,
ostentatious classical composers.
And the scenes that follow
carefully sketch out a character
that is haunted by their
own misuse of power.
We've seen this kind
of character in movies
endlessly time and time again.
It's one of film's most
time honored tradition
to examine the minutiae of
terrible, powerful people.
But Director Todd Field is
flipping things on their head
just enough that allows us a fresh glimpse
into this dynamic and how it can play out
not just across gender,
but across all kinds of
institutions of power
or places where we venerate a person
or artist above the value
of what they're doing
in and of itself
Lydia Tar would have you think
that it's only about the art,
but what haunts her is
that, really, for her,
it's about anything but that.
I think this movie is getting
misrepresented a little bit
as being a movie about cancel culture,
and it touches on that as a theme,
but I think it goes much, much deeper.
Above all, it's a rich,
expertly crafted character study
centered around maybe the
year's best performance
from Cate Blanchett.
This is a movie that I
know has more to offer
than what I absorbed
the first time through
and I can't wait to explore it further.
Back in April,
before "Everything Everywhere
All at Once" hit theaters,
A24 and the writers and
directors of the movie,
the Daniels, released a letter
explaining some of the motivation
behind why they made the movie.
In it, they talked about the
weird feeling and pressure
of asking an audience for
two hours of their time
in a world where it kind of
feels like there's already
objectively too much
stuff to ever be consumed.
I think it's a valid question.
It's one I think about a lot.
Why should you add to the noise
when it feels like what people
really need is less of it?
In the letter, they say this.
"We realized if we were
going to make a film
and ask an audience to
give us that precious time,
the only responsible thing to do in return
was to blow their minds and
change their lives forever.
Or at the very least, we
were going to attempt that."
At the time I read the letter, I was like,
"Okay, guys, chill."
What I didn't expect
was a movie that would
actually maybe come close to doing that.
I don't know if I would
say "Everything Everywhere"
changed my life,
but it did manage to tap
into the nerve of something
and portray certain ideas
that I would say are currently
kind of changing my life.
This is the only film that
has come anywhere close
to capturing the sheer chaos
of what life has sometimes felt like
over the past few years.
A feeling I personally linked
to spending too much time on
the internet and social media
in a video that I made about
the movie earlier this summer
that you can check out.
But this movie also captured
a crucial piece of something
that was very important to me this year.
There's a moment amid all the
absurd chaos of this movie
that I think is very powerful.
And it's powerful only
because of how chaotic
and completely over the top and ridiculous
the rest of the movie is.
I think it's very significant
that before there's any real change
for the characters in this film,
there's this moment where they completely
stepped back into utter
stillness and quiet
and examined the value of
the mystery of existence
at its very core.
The biggest lesson I
learned in my life this year
and one that has significantly
impacted my mental health
for the better is that the
answer to the overwhelming chaos
can't be found within the noise,
but only by removing yourself
from it into stillness.
It's why this sudden cut
to just two rocks sitting in the desert
had the most emotional impact on me
out of anything I saw
in a movie this year.
It's only by taking
time away from the chaos
that you can really recenter yourself
and humbly return with an understanding
of what truly matters.
It's the holidays
and I tend to think of
this as movie season,
not just because a bunch of great stuff
tends to drop at the end of the year,
but also because when you get together
with friends or family,
it's a great time to watch some movies.
That makes it the
perfect time to check out
my sponsor for this video, Mubi.
Mubi is an online
hand-curated streaming cinema
with amazing movies from
all around the world.
One of the movies I
highlighted in this list,
"Decision to Leave" by Park Chan-Wook
is available exclusively on Mubi.
And you can check that out
when you sign up for an
extended 30-day free trial
by going to mubi.com/thomasflight.
Mubi also makes a great gift
for people who love cinema.
Go to mubi.com/gifts
and you can choose from
between three months to a year to give.
Christmas is just a few days away.
This is a great last minute gift
for the other cinema lovers in your life.
Cinema is best when you can
share it with other people.
Go to mubi.com/thomasflight,
click the link in the description
below or on the screen
to sign up for your
extended 30-day free trial.
Thanks again to Mubi for
sponsoring this video
and for another great year.
(ambient music)